ah non non non je non je peux plus faire
l'amour avec vous messieurs je serais
quand même vous m'avez offert wind donc
à ce moment là je vous ai proposé de
venir dormir chez moi on a commencé une
vidéo mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
qu'est-ce que c'était ridicule moi parce
que je suis breton ma grand mère a
inventé la galette saucisse sextet a
tout de suite je vous faire chanter je
voulais passer ces scènes là aussi c'est
ma fille c'est un portable de la gauche
que la vidéo j'ai écrit 42 lettre
recommandée à facebook
aucune réponse rien je pourrais tu as vu
comme ça pourrit la mienne je vais te
spoiler la face moi tu vois c'est sur
l'application fiançailles à me taxi
driver et need more north star une
colonne toulouse et puis pierre gabas
electronics est nerveux a pris
[Musique]
vidéo ne soit partir l'enfer dans un
data center sécurisé mr départ de
datacenter
actustar
elle ne l'obtient
ces mamans ne t'a pas mon nom dans
internet s'il te plait je n'arrive pas
[Musique]